[Music]
xenon 3 or z3 as the kids call it no I
was not a kid wooden this came out and I
still know no kid ever called it this
he's the final and by far the worst in
the epic xenon trilogy the first film
was cheesy but creative and made use
with what it had the second film was a
serious downgrade but definitely tried
to keep the spirit of the first the
third just doesn't seem like it gives a
at all you can feel every moment
what an obvious cash in this is that the
first one wasn't trying to do that
either but it was trying to tell a story
first this feels like it wants to just
follow studio notes and then tell a
story yeah if there's time xenon is
staying with her aunt and uncle trying
to pass a driving exam so that she can
enter a competition to the moon yep it's
one of those comments faced driving
mountain climbing competitions that as
far as I know doesn't really have a
prize of much worth and seeing how she
can't parallel park yet can somehow win
this competition shows that she's
clearly ready but she can't do this
without a cute little kid sidekick and
her obvious ploy for a spinoff Zeena a
movie that never happened this is her
little cousin adopted by the aunt and
uncle and of course happens to be
obsessed with her dresses like her talks
like her and much like this movie is
entirely pointless yeah
you could cut her out from this flick
and you wouldn't miss a thing it's like
looking at dr.evil and mini me it's just
weird and unpleasant but something seems
to be up as some sort of weird silver
dust seems to be sabotaging the other
players forcing her in the lead she of
course has no problem with this and is
enjoying her lead when her friends
finally call her out on what adieu she's
been she just shrugs but things might
get complicated when this handsome boy
she has a crush on is protesting anyone
going to the moon because I don't really
know if they explained it they didn't
explain it very well or clearly but soon
Zeena doesn't want any people on the
moon either because the moon spirit yes
I I'm not even kidding is the one who's
been using the silver dust to get in
contact with her because she feels she's
the only one who can tell them to leave
the moon because she just doesn't like
them oh and she's not some for
less being or some elegant-looking goes
no she's just a goth girl like the moon
is a goth girl I have so many questions
she tells Zenon to kick everybody off
the planet and when she doesn't want to
she forces her to go down on the ground
and throw her up in the air and yeah
she's just kind of a bitch
but Xena for some reason sees her as the
hero and decides to tell everybody to
get off the moon but first she has to
win her friends back by apologizing oh
wait they forgive her without her having
to do a damn thing if you think that's
not enough to show how little this movie
cares remember that rock star from the
other movies he's in this again except
played by totally different actor and
what a shock he's entirely pointless I
think he brings a car that can help
transport them that's it I remember the
movie felt so long and getting itself
going that when I checked how long it
was I found I was only 10 minutes until
the end yeah it was so not interesting
that I assumed the real story hadn't
gotten started yet and by God we're
actually near the end I cared so little
because it feels like the movie cared so
little everything feels like it's there
because producers just look at some
charts all what was popular and throw it
into this movie remember how in the last
one she discovered aliens freaking
aliens where did they go as bad as the
second one got it at least felt like
something was on the line something
major was going on it just wasn't being
done very well in this one what do I
care if they leave the moon it's just
one little ain't the ass that's yelling
and screaming and you know what screw
her I want to live on the moon
the other two Zenon movie seemed about
exploring possibilities space travel all
that stuff this is like hey you want to
see this cool idea neither do i bye
what's this moon spirit even need Zeenat
she's constantly grabbing people
throwing them up in the air she can take
for him whatever she wants there's this
one scene where the guys like well if
this moon spirit is really bear show us
some proof and sure enough she shows up
and starts flinging people around before
I could talk to these people before I
know it seems stupid getting upset over
Zenon 3 but the first Zenon 4 as silly
as it was actually he had something good
in it it felt grounded in a certain
reality a childish one but still a
reality and it was about characters
adapting and learning things this is
just life lessons you learn on the back
of a Happy Meal box thrown in with
effects that somehow seemed worse than
the first one
ah this movie as crazy as it sounds is
surprisingly kind of forgettable aside
from the crazy as moon spirit which was
just so bizarre I couldn't forget it for
the life of me everything else is kind
of just in one ear and out the other
nothing seems relevant enough to make an
impact
it just seems relevant enough for you to
remember that Xena is a thing that
you're supposed to like well seeing how
they never made another one I'm assuming
that kids were starting not to like this
anymore
and with writing like this it's no
wonder is it annoyingly bad no is it
Cheetah Girls worthy not even by a
longshot but it's pointless dumb and
lacks any passion at the first one hat
or hell even the second one had I'd say
watch it only if you want to finish the
movies off but if not you can lose this
one in any wormhole
[Music]
you